hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments behind you penis mark what are
you gonna marry jack
well if Jack was good enough to deserve
me then maybe he would have a chance but
as it stands he's so terrible and stupid
and ugly and as a terrible accent all by
the way he's Irish
cept applier are done mark I have a
question do you listen to kpop if yes
then who's your favorite if no then why
okay kpop is Korean pop if anyone didn't
notice and I don't listen to them
because I frankly don't listen to all
that much music to begin with but it is
a little bit embarrassing that I have a
ton of family in Korea and yet I don't
participate in hardly any of their
culture my mom's actually in Korea right
now so if you're watching this mom my
mom pop you're having fun and also I
know this is the kpop nothing it's not
bad I don't like okay it's fine I mean
maybe it's better than J pop I don't
know and I probably just defended a pop
people hat entertain us mark entertain
us
so you said you're not gay but you never
said you were not bisexual so are you
just straight or bisexual well it pretty
much goes hand in hand that if I say I'm
not gay
then I'm not bisexual sorry to crush
everyone's dreams
I don't like penises except for my own
it's oh man how do you guys keep getting
me to talk about my dick no not bisexual
sorry except acquire a crash mark whose
idea was it to come up with the boner
podcast Oh
how oddly topical to the penis talk I
started this video off correctly well it
was I believe it was Bob and Jack's idea
originally and then they told us about
it in the proper videos that we did and
we couldn't stop talking about penises
not because we have a problem and not
because any of us are gay and or
bisexual we're straight were and that's
okay
also being gays okay we got no problem
with that we just have a rampant out of
a control love for penis and that's
alright like there's definitely weird
about that
we love talking about dicks getting
louder dear markiplier this is the
leader of a witch wizard coven and we
have seen your dark side in your
previous videos and the effectiveness of
your powers we'd like to recruit you and
see more extra points for killing a
little girl named Caroline or amorous um
no I want to be very clear I'm not a
witch and I'm definitely not a wizard
no big burly man by the name of Hagrid
burst down my door and told me that I'm
such so I'm not that I don't know about
no killing of little as demon-possessed
say maybe I have done no murder this is
sounding more suspicious by the second
the louder my voice gets will be very
clear
my life lad that matter is settled marks
serious question have you ever had an a
racist encounter before I'm truly
curious yes absolutely I have I grew up
in a small town so being from a small
town I was one of two Asian kids even
though I'm half asian I was one of two
days and kids in my entire school and
that was me and my brother oh and this
other guy he was full Korean but for
some reason no matter what it's like you
know drop in the bucket kind of sing it
doesn't matter and so growing up I had
to deal with a lot of you know Asian
jokes and a lot of people pointing out
the fact that I was Asian more than
pointing out the fact that I was marked
so yes I did deal with that and actually
my brother dealt with it more than I did
because he even had teachers that were
like openly prejudiced against him and I
didn't even know why I wasn't in the
class at the time but he could tell you
that like early on way early on he had
teachers that like openly belittle to
him just because he was part Asian and
it was a very bizarre situation it got
better over time mostly because you know
I started sticking up for ourselves and
my brother and I were just cool to begin
with but you know we were often we went
from a private school to a public school
about third grade and that transition
was hard because we'd never been in
public school before and we didn't
understand how everything works so when
we were very young you know we would you
bully one because we were Asian and that
did die down over time but you know it
never really left because it kind of
just became like oh my friends are gonna
make Asian jokes I just kind of have to
live with that until I realized that hey
I should probably tell them if it
bothers me and it did and then I told
them and then they stopped because it's
not like they were intentionally trying
to hate on me it's just that that's the
jokes they were making it was kind of
like the situation that it was and I'm
not saying that's good I'm just saying
that's how it was so yeah I did and I
lived through it and I learned from it
so
and I'm only late and that's the funny
thing I'm only half Korean but you know
it doesn't matter sometimes if you're
even a little bit different from what
people consider the norm to be then you
know you're an oddball you're the
oddball and a society has to come a long
way before that gets better and I'm not
saying I get it worse than some people
like you know like there's many many
many minorities that have way worse than
I did as a kid I'm just saying like this
is my personal experience and I hope
that as a society you know we can move
forward from that sort of stuff and not
recognize our differences for like the
outward stuff but our differences on the
inside and what makes us actually
different as people and specialists
people and recognizing us for our unique
talents and not our general gentlemen's
or general appearance you know each of
us is special in our own way and that's
a cliche but it's also true because we
have to recognize our own talents just
as much as other people need to have an
open mind recognize what makes each
person special so that's my career
where's chica right now all right chica
you peed on the floor so you get to wear
the Fedora of shame you wear at you wear
it wear the Fedora you chewed up you
wear it are you proud of what you've
done
are you proud mark I dare you to call
Wade insane a very sexy voice
top of the morning to you laddies
top of the morning to you laddies that's
not okay that's done okay wait I'll call
you back bye mark did you ever watch ed
ed and Eddy absolutely it was one of my
favorite shows that an old spongebob you
know what I'm talking about
season 1 through 4 spongebob not any of
the other stuff cuz that stuff got weird
but you know ed and Eddy who's a great
show I loved like the unique comedy that
that show had because it had like the
weird sound effect physical comedy and
that was really cool I mean that's a lot
of animation but it was just so well
done like the totally mismatched sound
effects were my absolute favorite and
the sumos you know like that's Oh God
every time that came up I was like a
stupid kid so obviously like that
anyway this boy at my school said that
you were not very funny and that you
have no life what should I tell him that
he's absolutely right I'm not funny I
replaced my humor with penises and then
I get by my daily life just thinking
about how I can make another dick if you
had a chance to rename wade what would
it be
Oh ask him Wade I need a solid favor
from you right now you got it say my
name is Captain mcburger but being a
part of that bottom of the morning to
you captain mcglue c'mon
hey Marco fart do you plan on meeting
more fans on omegle or something I'm
sure I'll do it right now hello
all right hi
you have a microphone right okay I'll
say something inspirational or something
that could help people who may be
struggling they're having a rough time
having a rough time
oh okay okay um no matter what happens
no matter what is going through your
like currently the things that will make
it feel a lot better like something will
show the tiniest and then will just make
your life a lot better I know what
raishin you're in it'll get better no
matter what although if you if you need
help you talk to somebody
oh if you need somebody to talk to
then the people online with people
around the world of people I have to
help you no matter what even the
smallest largest problem you have we
will listen to you and if you need help
them please find help but feel a lot
better you won't stay with you for the
rest of your life that's good thank you
very much what's your name my name is
Kate and I'm yeah was that Paige Paige
well thank you very much Paige I gotta
get going now but thank you thank you
very much thank you because you've
helped me a lot through a lot of
everything so thank you for making
videos and stuff because you're a
wonderful person and thank you for
everything else well thank you very much
for watching I hope you have a good day
you too you too bye okay so that was
reading your comments thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
and
I will do another omegle event very soon
i will do a full one this time so thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you for being there for me and take
those words of inspiration to heart
because they do mean lot and I'm really
glad that she Paige came out and said
those things so thank you again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye